check out the story it's not the biggest
story in the world but it needs to be
talked about
swat team sweeps homeless out of
washington state hotel that was taken
over by activists this should be
major news check this out two olympia
police swat teams two teams
went door to door at the red lion hotel
sunday night breaking up what police
called a forcible occupation
by homeless advocates other officers
escort out employees who were sheltering
in the basement for more than six hours
feeling trapped police said
seven people were detained seven people
were detained
are more and more arrests are expected
cbs affiliate cairo tv reports
the incident was similar to one seen
recently in fife washington
the activists from a group called oli
housing now paid for 17 rooms for one
night
moved in 33 homeless people and tried to
arrange for them to stay indefinite
without paying
they demanded that thurston county use
funds from fema to pay for rooms
we we're just ready to stand our ground
we don't mean any harm
we actually want this hotel to get
business that's the opposite of what's
going to happen by the way
police said they started receiving calls
at about 11am from hotel employees who
said people with batons
knives hatchets gas masks helmets and
goggles
had entered the lobby apparently
prepared for a confrontation
once uh officers estimated there were
about 45 members of the group inside and
out
now they just had batons knives hatchets
gas masks helmets and goggles but they
don't mean any harm
the knives are for buttering their bread
of course and and and making toast for
the homeless
the batons are for playing wiffle ball
out in the backyard and the masks those
are just to look cool oh everyone's got
to wear a mask it's kovan
they were being conscientious when they
decided to take over a hotel
i see you've done your due diligence
what you've
you've obviously looked into this no i'm
just ready i read the story
these people have staged an armed
occupation of a hotel
a private hotel that's right okay have
you heard did you hear about this
no but i'm kind of glad the swat team
came in and cleared them out
two swat teams wow raided a hotel
because far off
like far left activists with weapons
were threatening
hotel employees because they're
desperate for a place for people
to live yeah in the winter yeah
and you know the the it does underscore
very serious problems we have in
in in our country you know i was talking
about
jon stewart earlier he tweeted that
i guess in response to getting smacked
around by like these these late night
hosts
over his uh pro wall street vets comment
he said so if i do good at this do i
become president and then i was like
yeah become president what do you do run
on your unrelenting support for 9 11
first responders
yeah i totally vote for that no really i
would totally vote for that
jon stewart's awesome and the point i
was making is that we
will send 10 million dollars to
pakistani gender gender studies programs
you know for for what reason i have no
idea we'll send billions of dollars in
foreign aid
while we have people sleeping on the
streets now i'm not saying the solution
is just
giving these people homes or taking over
a hotel i worked for a homeless shelter
i've worked for non-profits the problem
is extremely complicated
many of these people are not well they
can't work even if they want to because
they're not well so what do we do we
don't just throw them in the street
well what happens is when our government
takes our money our tax dollars when
they print massive amounts of money
they strip our value away and their
buddies rip us off
they send that money overseas for god
knows what
and they do nothing to solve the problem
yeah and you end up with a bunch of
angry people who show up with batons and
that doesn't solve the problem either
but hey i can respect the anger to be
honest i'm sick of what i'm sick of the
money being wasted on on nonsensical
bull crap i don't understand how the
flint crisis went as
went on as long as it did with them
screaming and everyone knowing
and every lifting evidence secret
advocacy group saying these pipes are
getting led in the kids mouths
and it's like yeah but gender studies in
pakistan you know they need money for
those programs right
yeah and where did they get the money i
mean we're talking about income tax
sales tax
property tax capital gains tax which a
lot of people are going to be finding
out about very soon especially if you're
on reddit
inheritant tax i mean when you look at
the rate that the american people are
our tax i mean it's not as high as
europe but when you add it all up it's
it's absolutely
incredibly uh jaw-dropping to understand
how much money the government takes and
then
where do they spend the money as you
said you know
speed votes for sri lanka that was
literally in the budget bill
that was passed what's going on in
myanmar i hear there was a military
revolution that's a whole nother topic
is that has that been funded by but this
is another thing before we jump there i
want to finish on this topic here
particularly because
when you look at the homeless situation
it's about to get way
way worse not only because of the larger
financial tsunami coming our way from
the ramifications of the 2020 lockdowns
which they're coming
which we still haven't felt the full
ramifications of it's
going to hit people and it's going to
hit people hard economic flows usually
take months
usually even take sometimes years to
fully affect people but but this is
another thing we need to realize here
a lot of the homelessness issues are
surrounded mental health
mental health is plummeting in the
united states at a dramatic rate
when we see suicides self-harm
depression
going dramatically down and that's going
to cause another extreme situation
and when you have extreme situations
people are going to see extreme
solutions just like those people in the
hotels
and i'm not i don't want this to happen
what we're seeing is the extraction of
the system at the very last minute
i think that the the establishment
elites the politicians
the wall street bankers the big ceos and
all the stuff
they've given up they're looking at
everything and they're like ship's going
down
what should we do well grab as much of
the fine china and silverware as you can
get to and get to an escape boat and
then get out before anyone realizes the
ship's sinking
ship going down that's that's what it uh
that's what it feels like it feels like
the homelessness crisis the
the evictions that are looming the fact
that people aren't getting cash
right now their their businesses have
been destroyed the ship is about to
crash
they know it and so they're just like
let's just take what we can yeah they're
printing as much as they can buying as
much land as they can investing in as
much stock and stuff that's going to be
not investing right shorting the stocks
to make sure that they're
look they printed all this money most of
it goes to these massive corporations
they pay out their bonuses they buy land
they buy hard assets then the dollar
tanks then what
they leave you holding the bag
homelessness is pretty nasty
i agree with you i've also seen that
some people with mental disabilities or
whatever that are just are not in a
position that even if you give them a
place to stay
a job and a bunch of money they're going
to fail and land right back on the
street there are some people like that
but there are many people that are
homeless and what they need is a shower
and a bed they need a shower so that
they can clean themselves
so that they can become presentable to
get the job because if you stink
you're not going to get the job they
need a shower they need a clean shirt
they need a haircut they need to shave
and it's really hard to do when you live
nowhere right you have nowhere to go and
so
that's why i do like these shelters i
don't know
if we'll ever find a solution because
sometimes people become
destitute sometimes people you know they
can't phone they can't re
repurposing empty buildings for homeless
people why is that not why is that not
more common who maintains the building i
don't know
who where's the money come from they've
tried that in the past
and the buildings fall apart and they
become ghettos and then crime and
disease
it is a very real problem that we need
to find the root of and get to the root
of but
the reality is sometimes people become
homeless because they don't have the
mental
health required and i don't mean they're
crazy some people are too depressed
and it's a serious issue some people
have
schizophrenia some people have you know
psychotic disorders need medication
some people can't afford the medication
you get left with a large group of
people that
are just basically thrown to the gutter
and we have no real easy way to solve
the problem
it may not be a problem that can be
solved to be honest but we can mitigate
it properly
i don't think occupying a hotel solves
the problem in fact it's probably going
to make it worse not by force definitely
well ian we already have that we already
have section 8 housing we already have
projects
so there's government buildings where
people live in so
and they function of course you gotta
you gotta fly through hoops to get
into section eight like whereas a
homeless shelter you just walk in and
stay
if you look at this uh the you know
poverty rates it's usually a cycle
that just keeps spinning itself into
oblivion
with the way that the system has
established itself that
essentially screws people over with
either too much taxes too much
regulations too much on them
that decentifies anyone from from any
kind of economic mobility because
there's barely any left
you're talking about low-skilled jobs
they're replaced by immigrants you're
talking about high-skill jobs
they're replaced by visa programs for
immigrants
and then companies like elon musk get in
trouble for not hiring enough immigrants
so so where's the
where's the upward economic mobility
there isn't a non it's a
scam it's all a big system where people
with
within the banking system literally
print xero onto a computer
and that's how our financial system is
run meanwhile everyone else what do they
do
they they get stuck in this poverty
cycle that they never get out of because
there's no way out of it i'm thinking
two things either ubi
we print a bunch of money doesn't seem
to work and then this microsoft patent
zero six zero six zero six where we
implant
you know chips in these people and then
just their biometrics can earn them
cryptocurrency so that they have so much
just for being what if i don't think
implanting was anything having to do
with it
they might not have to implement you
could do a tattoo it could be something
you eat i don't know but you put
something in them or on them so that it
measures
their bio activity maybe a watch so that
you know are they looking at the
billboard if so they earn cryptocurrency
just sit there and watch them
i have a conspiracy theory what's that
ian's the elite
someone else said i was an arm of the ad
that i'm the avatar of the ai
that on twitter yes someone suggested
why is it because of these things i'm
talking about maybe i'm just like
you're encouraging because that would
lead us towards the matrix where people
are in pods like
generating heat for the system this
giant machine that's like controlling
everything but
otherwise we have homeless people all
over the street hitler's idea was
kill them he would he would wrap up all
these mentally you know
ill people and just have them killed
because they were ruining his society
that i don't want to do the matrix is
terrifying putting people in pods
but what do you do they're on the street
if they can't if they can't take care of
themselves there's poop everywhere
what do you do because we're animals
we're wild barely tamed animals and if
we're not mentally prepared
what kind of bet what do we do no idea i
look i worked for homeless i've worked
for a homeless shelter a network
there's no solution you know a lot of
homeless people refuse to go to shelters
and refuse to get jobs
that's another problem what do you do
can't solve the problem they they
they refuse you'll you'll you'll pull up
and you'll say
we've got a clean shower we've got a bed
we've got clothing and you don't got to
do anything you can just live there i'll
go now
i don't want to work for your system no
there's no work involved
literally we i i worked for a shelter
that would offer people
no questions asked room and board at a
house
you get your own key you come in the
back door you go right to your room no
one asks you any questions you have a
house you have a shower you have clothes
no they wouldn't take it
but but it's so in the meantime they're
out on the street just like polluting
the environment whatever literally like
crapping on the ground
blocking traffic terrifying people that
are walking by
so one one place in northern california
wants to rendition
that's probably the wrong word but they
want to take them and then gain power of
attorney over their finances
and that's part of the justification is
that you give these people even an
opportunity for a free place to live and
they refuse what do you do
so now they're saying they have the
right to just take these people for
mental health reasons and lock them up
see that leads towards what hitler looks
like hillary clinton absolute tyranny
absolute if like if somebody wants to
sit on the sidewalk
and you know in most places it's legal
to do you can't block the sidewalk
but they can't arrest you for being in
public and sleeping they'll
they they do sometimes uh in many places
they probably do
but in san francisco they'll get up
every morning if my friend kelly cutler
is like a community organizer for the
home of san francisco they'll come at
like 4 a.m with fire hoses
just hose everybody on the sidewalk they
have a department
it's pretty bad i think san francisco is
a really good example of what happens
when you have an
uh oligopoly when you've got zuckerbergs
and dorsey's controlling the system
and they're ultra wealthy elites who
pretend to be good people
dorsey's probably the worst because he's
like this hippie guy who talks about all
these great things
and then he's just a billionaire who
funds critical race theory and then
people are crapping on the street and
homeless and destitute but at least he
can fund critical race theory right
like that's solving the problem that's
solving the problem homeless people come
in from all
different backgrounds these these people
in silicon valley just want you to think
they're doing a good thing
so that way when you come with your
pitchfork you ignore them because
they're the good guys right
meanwhile they're actually making the
problems worse
yep yes i'm at a loss
yeah you know what what what really
frustrates me is that
it's the grifters it's the grifters man
what do you mean
there are people on the the there's
establishment individuals who pretend to
be on the left
who would waste their time pulling
quotes from me out of context for for
the goal of making a partisan rage bait
piece of content so like jimmy kimmel
no no no i'm talking about people on
youtube who are grifters
who take clips from this show out of
context you're talking about specific
people you're not naming
and they cut and edit them so that they
get you
or or luke or me saying things and then
they they
they use that so that people don't want
to listen to what we have to say
because if they did they'd be like hey
we we actually think a lot of the same
things we have green a lot of same
things
don't worry too much about that stuff no
that that is the problem
we're trying to unify the people against
the the machine that is stripping our
value away and destroying our lives
and what happens is you get grifters
useful idiots for the establishment
who go on their shows take clips out of
context from shows like this
and then say tim pool is far right when
like literally i'm pretty sure the
entire bent of this show has been fairly
left-wing
pro-social programs for the homeless
talking about wall street being bad
you'd think it would be a pretty
left-wing positive you know i did say i
like those swat teams
going in there and oh you're far right
that was kind of far right we were
pretty pro-gun
i guess that's a problem someone cut me
up and made me look really stupid
i'm already pretty stupid but like holy
cow that's not fair
why'd you do that i need more memes so
cut
i'll be fair we did this thing on
jacobin where we looked at the magazine
cover
oh yeah finding his jesus and we were
like laughing at them but the greater
context of the segment was about how
the left in general the establishment
left not the progressives
were overwhelmingly praising biden with
like sun the sun
clouds breaking and sunlight beaming
down on the inauguration and we were
just using the jacobin thing as a
launching point
but but to be fair we did not realize
initially
that it was meant to mock the exact same
thing however in that podcast we did say
oh man wait a minute there's drones on
the cover this is
probably parody it's like satire and
then i said well if it is you know we
deserve we deserve it right
the problem was you could have taken the
episode and watched it
and then been like guys we completely
agree with you you missed this though we
we were agreeing with you the whole time
and i'm like no look at that instead it
was used by a bunch of leftists to mock
and deride and insult this show even
though they agree with us
why why they agree with we agree with
them it's easy clicks
exactly these people are destroying our
opportunity to call out the
establishment i would say in regards to
that jacobin thing
i i said it earlier i don't think text
flies with sarcasm
you don't see it when you see text and
same with images you can't tell if
that's sarcasm or not
i mean for me it's like whatever it's
okay you did it i'm just gonna keep
focusing on my mission and my job and my
goals and i'm gonna try to reach them
i'm gonna try to help as many people as
i can
and if they want to do that let them do
it but at the end of the day no it's not
going to be lazy
it's not personal it's about right now
we have
on reddit these people going after the
machine and it's working
and we have a non-partisan issue where
everyone kind of agrees we're seeing
donald trump jr and aoc agree on the
same thing
the issue is not personal i don't care
if you call me a bunch of stupid names
and mock my appearance like they do
i don't care it comes the territory
don't expect to get into public you know
spaces and think everyone's going to
love you just not reality the issue i'm
worried about is not it's not personal
it's about how they do this to anybody
who might actually agree with them
that the tribe is more important than
the cause they will mock
like you ian uh probably agree with a
lot of these left-wing personalities
substantially more
than anyone we've had on the show like
especially criticisms of donald trump
but they would cut segments up of you to
make you look
like you're far right instead of just
being like we like this guy
because it's more for them the tribe is
more important than the cause
so my concern is we want to get people
to rally around what we all agree on and
build culture and community and support
for the things we can accomplish but the
grifters
are the ones who are destroying that
because they're more interested in
cliques and rallying people to hate each
other what we can do is not grift
if we can well we don't yeah i don't
i really don't think i do i really do
not i try not to take people out of
context man that
that what was that kid who who had the
native american dude in his face and he
was smiling
right covington i took that i i almost
snapped on that and that that was a
wake-up call for me to take
a mistake of taking people out of
context we'll have anybody from left
right up down whatever on this show
we clearly have you and i we have our
arguments you'll be very critical of
trump i wanted to argue with you more
today
[Laughter]
but but it doesn't it doesn't work for
them so like the one segment they did
where they made
where we were talking about jacobin they
had to edit it
to make luke look stupid because they
completely agreed with luke and every
point he was making but the democrats
so they made it seem like how do you
even get to see the image
i was just generally talking about the
larger principles of not worshiping
someone
uh who's in politics you shouldn't don't
they can't
they there can't be a podcast where
there's actually kind of a moderate view
on things
so they have to edit it out of context
but it's not personal it's more about
hey on the upside our our show about
jacob and got i don't know half a
million views whereas the clips probably
got a third of that or
you know this show is getting more views
than those clips so that's a good sign
well you know i just wish people would
maybe i think i don't know
the tribalism is a problem thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time